arrival Wheatley just making a little
video and one of my all-time favorite
games surgeon simulator and I know if
you've heard of it you play it it's
brilliant
hey anyway I'm just making this video
right to tell everyone about this little
what's not a little Easter eggs pretty
big Easter Egg pretty obvious as well um
I don't if you've ever played Team
Fortress 2 but if you like to meet the
medic video you have to buy this game
because you get to play the meet the
medic video pretty much so if you put
that little tape into that VCR player
you can basically play as it says there
perform an uber heart transplant which
is exactly what I'm gonna do now so as
with any rubric our transplant
I think the best method of smashing ribs
would be to use the engineer's wrench
because its massive
and hefty now you're probably thinking
Whaley that's wrong because there's a
baseball bat sitting right here left
there I would say this right a wrench is
a little bit more heft to it and it's
easier to manage than a baseball bat
with one hand using a baseball bat with
one hand it's considerably harder than a
wrench and you're also probably saying
you're not doing very well yourself well
what I would say to that would be it's
my game you know is you want to play it
yourself
go ahead I'm not gonna stop you I never
any power over anyone none except her
but he's gone now and I'm just
stop playing video games no anyway I
know for that yeah I'm just I decided
just to drag it over the the chest
really um because I'm lazy still works
you know what fine if I just clear all
this guff off it off this table I get I
think I'm gonna put all that stuff on
that table there random stone head I
think that's a medic I too in the game I
think we just twist a hand there open
the fridge now as you all know from the
medic video the heart that you're
supposed to put in his chest it's called
the mega baboon
which if you actually look there it says
make up the boon which is pretty cool
right so I'm just gonna set that there
and grab the little uber thingy with the
three prongs and just put it on and
that's that set so next tool I'm just
gonna have to grab the lungs
alright just gonna throw them in the
fridge it must stink up the place
yeah I just grabbed the second one there
there we go chop that in the fridge as
well right take out the boys nah it's
white it's a stomach liver probably the
stomach mmm right so I'm gonna have to
cut his heart now
the top bit of the heart I believe it's
called the art the aorta I think was a
regular school um okay
spies knife only choice could use the
machete but I'm not an animal
so okay just difficut if I could twist
my hand there just I'm not not doing too
well here I might just go back reset my
grip here so alright okay so that's
improved a little bit a little bit more
accuracy
hopefully not really hasn't really
helped house it sorry ma'am oh that was
lucky
I was very lucky any second I didn't
expect that to work I actually did
actually did work and turns out I'm
actually better than this than I thought
it was originally all right so just
Chuck that in there
close the door we don't want any smells
coming out the fridge do we know nobody
likes a smelly fridge right see now we
grab the mega baboon as we've seen in
the medic video alright and as in the
medic video I'll give this [ __ ] soy
the way but that was a bomb hope it
doesn't explode I don't think it will
so this little [ __ ] here is the the
medic gun and I have to position it in
such a way that it heals his chest over
and gives him the uber mega baboon heart
so in game he can actually turn into
like a super version of himself whenever
a medic comes up in you know does his
uber charge right so
it's like just oh this is fiddly is
anything that might suit just just
getting there wrong way wrong way
cuz I look carefully okay come on
careful
I do that there that should be actually
about yeah boom and there we go
I'll just hear this chest over and I
just give them a little bit of that hope
you enjoyed this let's play
I've been Wheatley and there you go
bye